Sometimes during debugging, there are situations where you want to ensure
that some property hold throughout the entire execution.
Let me give you an example for that:
suppose you have a very big Python program with dozens or even hundreds of modules,
and suppose that due to some designed decision, there is one global variable called flag
which is accessible from all these modules and all of these modules
could possibly change the value of flag; they read flag, they write into flag.
But now, you have a run in which flag should not be set and yet it is set.
And you have all these places in the program where the variable could be set,
but you don't know where this is.
What you want to have in this situation is a check that is executed
at every moment throughout the execution of the program
and which monitors the moment in which flag is set to true.
>From a previous unit, you may remember the tracing functionality in Python.
By using the sys.settrace function, you can specify a function,
here traceit, that it will be executed after every single line is executed in your program.
And we can set up this traceit function such that after every line,
it checks the status of the global variable flag and aborts execution as soon as flag becomes true.
As any such tracing function, it returns itself such that it will be executed with the next line.
As soon as you have such as checker in place, the flag will be checked
after every single line of execution and you will be able to monitor exactly where the flag is set.
And this of course is true for arbitrary data structures.
If you do have some data structures, say store, again which can be accessed
from lots and lots of places, then a call say to a store.checkRep will ensure that store
is consistent for every single line that's executed.
Just be sure to turn this off while store is executing its own methods
because, while these internal methods are running,
store would naturally violate its own internal data invariants.